in case you haven't noticed today is
Valentine's Day you wearing red you're
wearing pink you're happy a lot of
people may have love on their mind three
and ten American adults say that they're
single 42 percent of them say they're
looking to date or find a committed
relationship if that includes you
professional Matchmaker that's Maria
avgatinas is here with some tips to help
Maria we should tell you as a third
generation Matchmaker so she knows her
stuff she's the founder of Agape
matchmaking and she joins us don't you
guys love her dress with all that is
beautiful I love it those numbers are
not very inspiring three out of ten
people are single that's already a small
number and then less than half of them
are looking for a serious relationship
like that's a pretty small population
that's small I'm talking 1.5 or 15 of
the population right well if you think
about how many adults are currently
single you know and then also there's
different demographics in that dating
pool and also why are we making it seem
like being single is bad
no I think that's a really good point to
make because you know everybody knows
I'm single I'll talk about it all the
time but I don't want it to be a pity
party like oh woe is me because that
isn't how I'm feeling but I also believe
life is better when shared and you say
most people are one degree away from
meeting their person one degree away so
I'm looking around the room is he here
well Tony Klaus Brian they're all
married that's right when you say one
degree away what does that mean so the
truth is that the majority of us are one
degree away from our person if you're
it's okay that your colleagues are
married they have friends what I mean by
one degree I mean by that's a
measurement of your Social distance from
your person right so if your friend
group isn't helping you set you know set
you up and what I mean by that is I
don't want you to ask someone when are
you going to set me up I want you to say
hey next time you're out with your
friends or next time you have a barbecue
I need you to invite me yeah that way
you start meeting that friend group and
also find this opportunity to start
dating yourself and create a social
calendar that helps you meet new people
in the process to increase those chances
of your Social Network helping you meet
someone special I've been set up one by
friends sometimes and then I'll call
them and say are you mad at me about
something
somebody set me up with somebody who
said you'll like this lady said I'm a
really good cook I love me some shrimp
scampies I'd love to cook for you
friends can make really bad matchmakers
I will admit that yes but what I will
say is that this is why we don't want to
tell our friends when are you going to
set me up and set teller friends I need
you to invite me when you're out yes
that's what I did to meet my husband
right I made a list of the things that I
would like in a partner that I could
possibly have children with and then I
thought to myself which of my friends is
dating or married to someone like this
and I thought of two people and I went
to those two gentlemen and I said next
time you're out with your friends you
have to invite me one of them did a week
later he said hey I'm going to be in
Boston you think I said from New York oh
I'm not going to get on Amtrak no I got
myself on the Amtrak I went to Boston I
met nine of his friends four of them
would sing would be we're single one of
them would end up being my list oh I
like that I like it too that's setting
up your social uh Circle and in in the
physical form but also like birds with
feather flock together course of course
I thought oh these two people are
probably friends with the person I want
to be yeah no doubt right but there are
a lot of people that are online dating
that don't go that route yeah and you
saying such a fantastic tool yeah and
you say that it's key for people to help
their matches self-select themselves yes
what I mean by that is this is when you
should look at your prompt so if you're
online dating look at your prompts and
ask yourself am I talking about myself
am I talking about my values because
most people what they'll say on their
prompts is oh tell me about the best
place we can get a martini or I don't
want someone who voted this way stop
talk about the podcast you like to
listen to talk about how you have a
group chat with your siblings talk about
the things that you value because this
is what's going to attract people to
self-select themselves uh through your
promise I just say I really appreciate
your guidance on the photos the photos
need to look like you the first one
should be you looking into the camera
and smiling and the second one should be
a full body shot that says this is what
I will look like when I show up on our
date yeah you don't understand people
send me a professional Matchmaker photo
to set them up and I'm like and then
I'll meet them in person I'm like
when is this photo from
2017. wow that's a different person
that's pre-pandemic you you know so it's
very you know you have to keep in mind
uh that that person's date experience
the person you're meeting reality has to
meet expectations that's one of the
reasons why people don't go on do you
think it's harder to date now Maria if
you're if you're a single person in this
country regardless of your age it is
harder for two reasons one we're all
just thumbing away I remember when you
know I remember dating in college when
there was more analog dating and I could
count on my friends going to the
restroom where I could meet someone you
know oh can I get you a drink no one
does that anymore right we're all just
summing away on our phones right and
then the second reason why it's harder
is because online dating again it's a
great tool it has distorted what we
think we want sure so if you were at the
open bar at a wedding maybe he's five
foot six you're five foot two you don't
care right but online like well he's got
to be six feet tall
uh Matchmaker Maria thank you very much
awesome really great